every week here in our style show you
ask us questions and today we've got
some answers so we did a video about GQ
editors and their hair secrets that's
got Jay said a man bun said he only
washes his hair twice a week so Jerry
asked twice a week am I the only male
who wash my hair's every single day I'm
not the only male that's funny if there
was such a thing as a hair doctor they
would tell you don't want to shampoo
your hair every day it'll be frizzy and
brittle and dry you want some of the
natural oil now when we say wash your
hair we mean like using shampoo or using
shampoo and conditioner you can still
take a shower every day you can still
get your hair wet every day but you
don't need to wash your hair every day
it's just bad for your hair I'm a
once-a-week guy but you know different
people have different approaches so we
are going to go back to GQ editors
people on staff at GQ and Hasselhoff and
they wash their hair yeah yeah I was
washing my hair like ten times a week
like almost every time that I worked out
and it's the first thing when I got in
the office is people looked at me like I
was like a serial killer I want to work
to have maybe like three three times a
week every day about once a week never I
don't need to so we have designer John
Eliot in the office to talk about
tailored sweatpants there's a big trend
and Justin Baldwin comments our ass all
caps what if I have big ass legs and as
a very good question because we're all
different shapes and sizes some brands
work for us other brands don't if John
Eliot sweatpants are too skinny for you
or not right for you for other reasons
there are plenty of tailored sweatpants
out there you just want that tapered fit
and they elastic at the bottom I would
recommend Ralph Lauren denim and supply
I would recommend Nike makes sense right
I would recommend champion especially
Todd Snyder for champion which is a
collaboration between the fashion
designer Todd Snyder and the classic
like boxing and fitness brand champion
Justin I hope that
mr. binky 21 asks can you do a segment
on how to kindly tell your friends that
they need to up their style and then
there's a tongue out emoticon don't be
passive-aggressive be very direct
hey man I've known you a long time I
wouldn't be telling you this if I didn't
think you needed to hear it you bought
some new jeans and they're funny-looking
you should have just stuck with Levi's
you know maybe it's time you change
barbers as that person who really
doesn't know what they're doing you care
way too much about your sneakers it's
getting embarrassing we're going out to
dinner and you keep looking at your
sneakers and you keep cleaning them off
nobody cares about sneakers that much
man you've gotta stop never gonna get
laid ever commenter jal elite in autumn
is closing in what are the trends color
schemes for 2015 autumn Joe I'm glad you
asked that question what am i named five
plaid business suits the color camel
could be the top coat could be a sweater
shearling coat like a big cheer like
Marlboro Man style coat with lamb's wool
lining we've been seeing a lot of NBA
players wearing turtlenecks which is
like an old Hollywood thing that's being
brought back and last but not least I'm
gonna go with anything that Jean Michel
Basquiat worn you know the artist if you
google him and wear what he was wearing
that'll be good it may sound like I just
named those friends off the top of my
head but I didn't they actually came
from and plug alert ready
GQ style hour it's the 30 essential
trends of the season this is a biannual
fashion magazine that we make every
season so they're all new get it we're
don't
so myself and GQ fashion editor John
teats did a video about how to upgrade
your suit and Julius bass suggests how
about shape and take a bath now I saw
this comment and I went and rewatched
the video and I got to say the man's got
a point
next time we do a suit video I'll try to
smell jacket you know how I smell you
guys keep asking questions in the
comments then I will come on here and
answer them so comment away ask away and
keep coming back every week for our new
style videos thanks